neuanfang am strand der g 7 gipfel in
cornwall will wieder gestalten statt
streiten und fortschritte machen bei
herausforderungen wie corona klima oder
china die grünen und die härten des
wahlkampfs nach fehlern und pannen soll
der parteitag die stimmung drehen und
das wahlprogramm beschließen
gute nachricht für den urlaub sommer ab
juli hebt deutschland seine krone
reisewarnungen für etwa 100 länder auf
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers einen guten abend
hinein an diesem freitag wir freuen uns
dass sie dabei sind und es gibt ja noch
ein weiteres wichtiges thema heute
christin die fußball europameisterschaft
geht das wunderschön deutschland steigt
am dienstag 1 gleich gegen weltmeister
frankreich joachim löw abschiedstour die
wird spannend in rom geht es heute in
zwei stunden los und wir können uns das
mal schnell angucken die türkei gegen
italien fast 30 grad strahlender
sonnenschein jede menge fans corona
auflagen aber auch viel gute laune und
vorfreude
rom hat im historischen zentrum an
mehreren plätzen leinwände aufgebaut auf
denen spiele übertragen werden
und es gibt auch ein zentrales fanfest
dazu mehr gleich bei uns erst in die
politik denn auch da passiert heute viel
es macht einen riesenunterschied wenn
man sich persönlich trifft sagt der
gastgeber der britische premier boris
johnson im schönen cornwall an der küste
ist g7-gipfel zum ersten mal nach
längerer pandemie unterbrechung sind die
mächtigen der sieben wichtigen
westlichen industriestaaten und japan
alle wieder selbst vor ort der blick auf
die themen zeigt die staats- und
regierungschefs wollen ganz dicke
brocken anpacken den kampf gegen die
pandemie den klimaschutz die frage wie
kann man die welt konjunktur ankurbeln
und wie umgehen mit china und russland
andreas köhlers berichtet von tag 1 für
die deutsche kanzlerin ist dieser
g7-gipfel der fünfzehnte der letzte und
der erste den sie mit einem fehler
beginnt nicht die hand geben rufen die
mitarbeiter die pandemie bestimmt das
protokoll und die agenda von der küste
cornwalls will gastgeber boris johnson
den ärmeren staaten ein versprechen
senden dass die g7 mindestens eine
milliarde impfdosen spenden allein 500
millionen steuern die usa bei für joe
biden ist dieser g7-gipfel der erste
nach fünf jahren jump wollen die usa die
andern sechs wieder um sich versammeln
dafür kommt beiden mit großen
versprechen gerechtere welt gerechtere
steuern wirksamerer klimaschutz merkel
gefällt das beiden zum ersten mal zu
können ist natürlich etwas wichtiges
denn er präsentiert und repräsentiert
das bekenntnis multilateralismus das uns
den letzten jahr gehört manches ändert
sich nicht auch beiden wird von den
verbündeten mehr verlangen mehr härte
zum beispiel gegenüber russland und
china
merkel und makro skeptisch sie haben vor
dem gipfel vor einer neuen blockbildung
gewarnt von den protesten bekommen die
weltenlenker wenig bis gar nichts mit
hunderte finden die klimaschutzziele
noch immer zu niedrig die impfstoff
spenden noch immer zu geizig und die
selbstkritik noch immer zu klein
wir müssen unsere lektion aus der
pandemie lernen und sicherstellen dass
wir die fehler die wir in den letzten 18
monaten zweifellos gemacht haben nicht
wiederholen
bis sonntag wollen die g7 versuchen
wieder zu werden was sie auch vor der
tramp zeit nicht immer waren eine
wertegemeinschaft einige versprechen
haben wir da heute bereits gehört geben
wir live nach cornwall zu diana
zimmermann nahm die jahner was kann denn
dieser g7-gipfel entscheidendes für
unser aller leben bewirken
naja wenn tatsächlich nach diesem gipfel
eine milliarde impfdosen an arme länder
geschickt werden dann macht das
natürlich für die empfänger schon mal
einen gigantischen unterschied auch wenn
es vielleicht nicht reichen wird die
welt zu impfen
die boris johnson gesagt hat von diesem
gipfel soll ganz klar die botschaft
ausgehen dass die g7 wieder ein klub
liberaler demokratien sind nach donald
trump die erkannt haben dass sie nur
gemeinsam die großen probleme lösen
können wir sehen ja jetzt in der
pandemie des america first oder briten
first eben nicht funktioniert ist nichts
nützt nichts wenn in den
industrienationen alle durchgeimpft sind
wenn das virus sich immer weiter
verbreitet in afrika oder auch indien
dann entstehen varianten wie jetzt delta
die den imf erfolg aller gefährden und
das ist die große botschaft die von hier
aus geht und sie macht sehr wohl einen
unterschied denn sowohl in der pendeln
pandemie als auch
im klimaschutz ist es eben wesentlich
dass alle zusammenarbeiten so können wir
nur hoffen dass die ziele die hier
gesteckt werden wirklich ehrgeizig sind
und dass sie dann auch umgesetzt werden
diana zimmermann live in cornwall
herzlichen dank dafür
und jetzt zurück nach deutschland und
doch gleich wieder in die welt viele in
deutschland freuen sich auf eine
urlaubsreise wissen aber noch nicht so
recht was im zweiten sommer alles
möglich ist für mehr klarheit und mehr
möglichkeiten hat jetzt das auswärtige
amt gesorgt es gibt neue gelockerte
empfehlungen und regeln für
auslandsreisen nudel ein haus mit einem
überblick
die liste der korona risikogebiete wird
kürzer jetzt am sonntag werden wieder
zahlreiche regionen gestrichen
ganz österreich in der schweiz nun auch
die kantone bern und thurgau teile von
griechenland zypern kroatien serbien das
kosovo bosnien und herzegowina island
norwegen kanada und die usa zum ersten
juli
große änderungen bei den reisewarnungen
für rund 100 länder mit einer sieben
tage incidents unter 200 werden sie
aufgehoben nur wo länder darüber liegen
oder gefährliche virus varianten haben
gelten die reisewarnungen dann noch also
in denen derzeit 25 hoch inzidenz
gebieten unter anderem ägypten tunesien
namibia und sri lanka auch in den virus
varianten gebieten gelten die warnungen
weiter darunter brasilien indien
südafrika und großbritannien
unser nächstes thema bündnis 90 die
grünen haben sich einiges vorgenommen
die bisher kleinste oppositionsfraktion
im bundestag schielt auf das kanzleramt
glänzende umfragezahlen unterfütterten
zunächst den regierungsanspruch doch
nach einigen patzern gerät
spitzenkandidatin annalena baerbock
unter druck neuen schub soll aus sicht
der grünen jetzt der parteitag bringen
und das wahlprogramm patricia wiedemeier
berichtet es sollte eigentlich ihr
parteitag werden erstmals in ihrer
geschichte wählen die grünen eine
kanzlerkandidatin doch zahlreiche fehler
von annalena baerbock im vorfeld sorgen
für unruhe
die umfragewerte sind gesunken die
partei ist sichtlich nervös
rückendeckung daher gleich zu beginn für
baerbock
sie führt mit klaren kompass und
meistert die herausforderung dieser zeit
mit herz und verstand sie ist die frau
der zukunft
es sind 100 neue mitglieder im saal die
bei diesem weitgehend digitalen
parteitag für ein wenig stimmung für ein
gefühl von aufbruch sorgen sollen
die grünen sie wollen regieren die
zukunft gestalten der parteivorsitzende
verspricht den wahlkampf des lebens sie
fordern den ökologischen umbau der
wirtschaft und mehr klimaschutz
gerechtigkeits politik und
klimaschutzpolitik sind nicht zwei
beliebige polen
sie gehören zusammen und sie müssen
zusammen gedacht und zusammen
durchgesetzt werden
doch ob der programmentwurf so
angenommen wird ist fraglich es gab über
3000 änderungsanträge vor allem beim
thema klimaschutz werden heftige
kontroversen erwartet gefordert wird
unter anderem ein höherer co2 preis die
grüne jugend geht in vielen punkten noch
weiter wir wollen einen sofortigen
anstieg der grundsicherung von 200 euro
und wir wollen auch noch mal die debatte
rund um vergesellschaftung von großen
immobilienkonzernen mit in den parteitag
bringen und werden auch nach abstimmung
haben zum wahlalter trotz wahrscheinlich
heftiger diskussionen noch heute abend
die grünen wollen nicht weiter über
selbst gemachte fehler reden und weg vom
image der verbots partei auffallend oft
betonte robert habeck den wert der
freiheit und für uns beobachtet den
parteitag in berlin
ralf schumacher genannt ralf wir haben
es gerade schon kurz gehört eine ganze
reihe von anträgen
wenn du heute abend verhandelt heiße
eisen mit dabei welche grundlegenden
pflöcke ziehen denn die grünen da jetzt
inhaltlich ein für den fall dass sie
nach der wahl an die macht kämen ja
heute geht es da zunächst um schärferen
klimaschutz um die erhöhung des co2 co2
preises was er automatisch höhere
benzinpreise nach sich zieht um
tempolimits und um ein schnelleres aus
für verbrennungsmotoren
der programmentwurf der parteispitze ist
ambitioniert soll aber gleichzeitig neue
wählerschichten nicht verschrecken was
wir beschließen sollte umsetzbar sein
sagt robert habeck eine klare ansage an
viele forderungen der basis die sind
teils deutlich radikaler als es den
wahlkampfstrategen lieb ist das werden
spannende debatten hier ausgang offen
kanzlerkandidat in der woche erlebt ja
zuletzt sinkender umfragewerte und
wahlkampf pannen wie wird sie damit
umgehen auf dem parteitag
annalena baerbock wird erst morgen zu
den delegierten sprechen von robert
habeck er im ko vorsitzende dazu in
seiner rede gerade nur wenige sätze am
rande die parteispitze versucht die
pannen und peinlichkeiten
herunterzuspielen ärgerlich ja aber
nicht wahlentscheidend zu die linie
trotzdem das alles hat die grüne
euphorie ausgebremst die partei ist
verunsichert kämpft unglaubwürdigkeit
der offiziellen nominierung box morgen
zur ersten grünen kanzlerkandidaten gibt
es aber keinen zweifel
ralf vielen dank im bundestag rückt die
sommerpause mehr auf den letzten metern
standen heute aber noch viele wichtige
entscheidungen an
unter anderem beschlossen dass
lieferketten gesetz große unternehmen
müssen in zukunft genauer hinsehen wie
ihre internationalen zulieferer arbeiten
über allem steht die einhaltung der
menschenrechte
ziel ist es kinderarbeit ausbeutung und
die zerstörung der natur zu stoppen
sonst drohen bußgelder für die einen
geht die reform zu weit anderen nicht
weit genug klaus brodbeck
sie machen sogar noch mehr als das neue
gesetz vorsieht und schon seit langem
ein hersteller von naturkosmetik und
arzneimitteln in baden württemberg wir
prüfen unsere hersteller wo immer es
geht bis zurück zum ursprung und zwar
wirklich auf herz und nieren also das
bedeutet nachhaltigkeit im sozialen
bereich im ökologischen aber auch im
ökonomischen bereich freude bei
entwicklungs und sozialminister müller
und heil feiern das gesetz auch als
ersten schritt zu einer europäischen
einigung anstand und wohlstand das darf
kein gegensatz sein und anständige
unternehmer die sich kümmern dürfen
keinen nachteil auch kein
wettbewerbsnachteil dazu haben millionen
von kindern nämlich zur schule gehen
sondern in miedern arbeiten in
steinbrüchen arbeiten der auf plantagen
damit wir unseren kaffee trinken können
dieses lieferketten gesetz liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das war
teamwork gegen extrem starkes lobbying
vor allem der wirtschaftsflügel der
union hatte sich lange gewehrt
menschenrechtsorganisationen gehen die
regelungen längst nicht weit genug
die wirtschaft andererseits fürchtet
nachteile vor allem in der industrie
geben
43 prozent der unternehmen an negative
auswirkungen vor allem durch erhöhte
bürokratie zu erwarten
2023 soll das gesetz in kraft treten
gewerkschaften können dann zb gegen
menschenrechtsverletzungen und klagen es
eilt nach vielen jahren nimmt
kinderarbeit neuerdings wieder zu und
der bundestag hat noch mehr beschlossen
zum beispiel die pflegereform
beschäftigte in der altenpflege sollen
nach tarif bezahlt werden
gleichzeitig müssen pflegebedürftige für
einen heimplatz weniger zu zahlen
außerdem eine quote für mehr frauen im
top management der deutschen wirtschaft
sie gilt für große börsennotierte
unternehmen bei mehr als drei
mitgliedern im vorstand muss mindestens
eine frau dabei sein und dann das
transparenzgesetz mit strengeren regeln
für abgeordnete des bundestages künftig
soll deutlicher werden
was parlamentarier nebenbei verdienen
schule zu schule auf und schule wieder
zu dieses hin und her im pandemie zeiten
soll nach möglichkeit zu ende sein sagen
die kultusministerin und minister der
länder und wollen das im kommenden
schuljahr wieder der normale alltag in
die klassenzimmer einzieht also alle
zurück in den sogenannten
regelunterricht ein anfang doch viele
probleme bleiben antje klingbeil
vorfreude auf den schultag hier an der
grundschule in fürstenwalde
es ist die zweite woche mit etwas
normalität nach anderthalb jahren
wechsel unterricht erleichterung
die negativen folgen des homeschooling
zeichnen sich ab lern lücken erhöhter
medienkonsum psychische probleme nun
will die politik dass alle schüler ob
geimpft oder nicht nach dem sommer
wieder fünf tage pro woche zur schule
gehen
das bedeutet dass wir von am regel
hatten präsenzunterricht in allen
fächern allen jahrgängen ausgehen
monatelang kein regulärer unterricht
besonders problematisch für kinder mit
hohem betreuungsbedarf heute hat der
bundestag den rechtsanspruch auf
ganztagsbetreuung für alle grundschüler
ab 2026 beschlossen mehr zeit in der
schule mehr chancengleichheit egal wo
sie wohnen können sie sich darauf
verlassen dass die kinder im
grundschulalter verlässlich von montags
bis freitags qualifiziert betreut werden
doch die qualifizierten lehrer brauchen
mindestens sechs jahre ausbildung der
rechtsanspruch ist grundsätzlich
sinnvoll und wünschenswert
es ist jedoch schwer vorstellbar dass
dafür auch die entsprechenden kollegen
zur verfügung stehen um diesen anspruch
auch zu realisieren ist dahin müssen
zudem die jetzt aktiven lehrer und
lehrerinnen fit gemacht werden für
digitalen unterricht in und nach der
pandemie noch etwas mehr als 90 minuten
dann geht's los dann ist fußball
europameisterschaft ein jahr später als
eigentlich geplant und nicht nur das es
ungewöhnlich 24 teams spielen bis zum 11
juli den europameister aus und zwar in
elf verschiedenen städten
einmal quer über europa verteilt von
sevilla in spanien hoch bis nach glasgow
schottland im osten sankt petersburg und
baku aserbaidschan als hauptstadt der
staat heute ist in rom die deutsche
fußball-nationalmannschaft spielt in
münchen alle ihre vorrundenspiele die
arena kann dabei zu einem fünftel
besetzt sein und auch die lust auf
public viewing ist wieder da auch wenn
noch einige fragen bleiben aus berlin
romanesco war die bewohner dieses
berliner hauses schon in voller em
stimmung flatternde fahnen aller
teilnehmerländer ansonsten noch nicht so
viel zu sehen von typischer
fußballbegeisterung corona bedingt große
events wie die fanmeile am brandenburger
tor abgesagt unterschiedlich die
vorfahrt
also bei mir ist es auf alle fälle da
das wm-fieber ich werde gucken
ich habe mich auch dementsprechend
vorbereitet aber er sollte diese
euphorie ist noch nicht da aber auch den
anderen öffentlichkeit dass das gar
nicht so intensiv wahrgenommen wird wie
es schon mal so war
einige veranstalter setzen trotzdem auf
public viewing in berlin asola club
sogar mit 32 quadratmeter screen unter
strengen hygiene konzept registriert und
corona testpflicht auch im zoll parkhof
biergarten ist alles etwas kleiner
geraten nur vier bildschirme auf denen
auch nicht alle spiele gezeigt werden
der technische aufwand ist auch bei
kleinerer besetzung ist natürlich auch
im entschieden haben müssen die technik
wieder zurück geräumt werden muss
gemacht werden angebote zum public
viewing wird es vielerorts geben in
deutschland wie auch hier in düsseldorf
und doch wenn sich im biergarten viele
auf die em freuen
vorsichtig wollen sie trotzdem bleibt
wenn man sozusagen sich daher einmal
getestet hat ja so wie wir das hier
gemacht haben ich glaube dann ist es
halbwegs in ordnung die meisten
irgendwie auch ein oder zwei mal schon
genug fanmeilen freudentaumel dieses
jahr aber auf jeden fall tabu
stattdessen fußballschauen im kleineren
kreis was durchaus auch spaß machen kann
so jetzt em im fernsehen der sportliche
teil mit kristen wir gucken mal auf die
deutsche mannschaft zum 13 mal ist
deutschland bei einer em runde dabei
dreimal reichte es zum titelgewinn
zuletzt 96 vor fünf jahren das aus im
halbfinale gegen frankreich dem sie
schon gehört jetzigen auftaktgegner
dienstagabend da muss bereits alles
passen
gute stimmung teamgeist und
mannschaftliche geschlossenheit sind
durchaus hilfreich beim fotoshooting und
auch im spiel
genau diese trümpfe nämlich will das dfb
team bei der em aus spielen am besten
gleich zum auftakt gegen frankreich mein
gefühl ist eigentlich eigentlich ganz
gut nur wie gesagt am ende der tage geht
es dann dienstag los und entscheidend
ist auf dem platz dort kann aus heiterem
himmel durchaus ungemach drohen mats
hummels kam am ende mit dem schrecken
davon anders jonas hofmann dem droht mit
einer knieverletzung die auszeit zur
unzeit
sechs wochen vor olympia überraschungen
durch anna maria wagner bei den
judo-weltmeisterschaften in budapest als
erster judoka gewinnt sie nach 28 jahren
gold für deutschland in der klasse bis
78 kilo gegen die französische
weltranglisten erste madeleine malonga
tennisprofi alexander zverev hat seinen
ersten final einzug bei den french open
in paris verpasst trotz einer tollen
aufholjagd nach 0 2 satzrückstand
unterliegt er in fünf sätzen dem
griechen stefano celozzi pass es ist ein
hartumkämpftes match in dem der grieche
ging alexanders wäre phasenweise ganz
starkes tennis zeigt was man deutschen
zwei sätze lang schulterzucken
hervorruft im weiteren verlauf aber
wendet sich das blatt schwerer spielt
offensiver und variantenreicher gewinnt
satz drei und vier
der entscheidende fünfte satz geht
jedoch nach einem ass mit 631 ipass
schwere verpasste damit sein zweites
grand slam finale nach den us open 2000
20 jetzt geht es auf rasen weiter in
halle/westfalen christi vielen dank dann
steuerlich gegen ende der sendung das
wetter bei außer im nordosten überall
sonne und bis zu 29 grad warm mehr dazu
gleich von katja oliver ich empfehle ich
den kollegen claus kleber im heute
journal um 21.45 vom freien zum fairen
handel weltweit er hat fragen an den
bundesentwicklungsminister so viele von
uns für heute danke dass sie dabei waren
gerne bis morgen aber erst in allen
einen sehr angenehmen abend
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren jetzt
kommt das kleine tief wieder heran und
das bringt seine kaltfront und diese
kaltfront bringt auch ein wenig regen
mit viele von uns dürfen sich aber schon
morgen auf das nächste hoch jona
einstellen heute nacht also feldern
werden küsten von nord- und ostsee etwas
regen sonst ist es meist nur locker
bewölkt und es wird eine milde nacht im
rhein main gebiet und auch an der elbe
sinken die temperaturen nicht unter 17
grad am alpenrand wird es kühler mit 11
8 morgen liegen dann die
höchsttemperaturen hinter der kaltfront
an der küste nur so bei 17 bis 20 grad
in norddeutschland sind es 22 bis 24
grad im süden geht es dagegen zum teil
bis 28 grad aus und diese kleine
kaltfront mit dem bisschen regen zieht
morgen etwas südwärts und wenn sie das
erzgebirge erreicht haben wird dann
reißen die wolken heran der küste schon
wieder auf einen bürgen nordwestwind
gewitter bleiben die ausnahme im
südwesten wird es schon morgen sehr
freundlich und sehr freundlich wird dann
auch der sonntag bei relativ tiefen
temperaturen bei 17 bis 26 grad das sage
ich ihnen deswegen weil es danach
deutlich wärmer wird die temperaturen
steigen zum teil bis 32 grad
schönen abend noch